Sabe aquele mineral de que ninguém fala,
mas que pode estar por trás da sua
densidade fraquinha e até daqueles
hormônios femininos que andam meio
bagunçados? Eu vou revelar hoje um
segredo que muitos médicos simplesmente
ignoram. Não é cálcio, não é vitamina D,
é algo bem mais sutil, mas com um poder
tremendo sobre o seu esqueleto e o seu
equilíbrio moral. Se você é mulher e
passou dos 40, preste atenção nos
próximos minutos, porque isso pode mudar
completamente a forma como você cuida da
sua saúde óssea e hormonal. Eu estou
falando Boro. Isso mesmo, Boro.
Provavelmente você nunca ouviu falar
dele com muita ênfase, mas pesquisas
recentes publicadas em 2024 e 25 estão
mostrando uma verdade fascinante. O boro
é um dos minerais mais subestimados
quando o assunto é metabolismo ósseo e
equilíbrio hormonal.
Especialmente para mulheres na menopausa
e pós-menopausa. Esse mineral traço que
está presente no solo e nas plantas tem
um papel discreto, mas poderoso na forma
como o nosso corpo lida com cálcio,
magnésio e vitamina D. E aqui está o
pulo do gato. Ele também regula a
produção e o tempo de vida dos homônios
sexuais, incluindo estrogênio e
testosterona. Sim, testosterona as
mulheres também é importante pra
energia, força muscular, libido e
clareza mental.
Deixa te explicar como isso funciona. O
boro age como uma espécie de maestro
metabólico. Ele não é apenas um
coadjuvante. Estudos recentes mostraram
que quando mulheres pós-menopusicas
aumentaram a ingestão de boro de apenas
0,25 mg para 3,25 mg por dia, algo
interessante aconteceu. Os níveis de
estradiol, que é a forma mais potente
estrogênio, aumentaram. A testosterona
também subiu e o mais curioso, a
excreção urinária de cálcio diminuiu
drasticamente. Sabe o que isso
significa? Na prática o corpo começou a
reter mais cálcio ao invés de jogá-lo
fora pela urina. E cálcio retido é
cálcio disponível para fortalecer os
ossos. Mas o boro vai além disso. Ele
aumenta a meia vida biológica, tanto
estrogênio quanto da vitamina D. Isso
quer dizer que essas moléculas ficam
ativas por mais tempo no organismo antes
de serem degradadas. Pensa comigo, é
como se você estivesse fazendo o seu
estrogênio e sua vitamina D renderem
mais. E tem mais uma sacada
interessante. O boro parece inibir uma
enzima chamada 24 hidroxilase que é
responsável por degradar a vitamina D.
Ou seja, ele funciona como um freio no
processo que destrói a vitamina D,
permitindo que ela circule por mais
tempo e exerça os seus efeitos benéficos
sobre os ossos e sobre o sistema
imunológico. Um estudo piloto feito em
2024 com mulheres pós-menopáusicas que
tinham osteoporose mostrou uma
correlação forte positiva entre a
ingestão de boro e a densidade mineral
óssea. As mulheres que consumiam mais
boro tinham ossos mais densos.
Interessante, não é? E aqui tem um
detalhe técnico que vale mencionar.
Embora o estudo tenha encontrado uma
correlação negativa entre boro e cálcio
sérico, isso não é necessariamente ruim.
O que acontece é que o cálcio sérico, ou
seja, do sangue não reflete o status de
cálcio do corpo inteiro. O organismo é
experte em manter o cálcio do sangue
estável, mesmo que isso signifique tirar
cálcio dos ossos. Então, se o boro está
aumentando a absorção de cálcio pelos
ossos, é natural que menos cálcio fique
boiando, circulando o sangue. Agora vem
a parte que mais me fascina na abordagem
integrativa. O boro não age sozinho, ele
é um potencializador. Ele melhora o
metabolismo de outros nutrientes
essenciais, principalmente magnésio,
cálcio e fósforo. Se você está tomando
suplementos desses minerais, mas o seu
nível de boro está baixo, você pode não
estar absorvendo e utilizando esses
nutrientes de forma eficiente. É como
ter uma Ferrari na garagem sem gasolina
no tanque. O boro é essa gasolina
metabólica que faz tudo isso funcionar
melhor. E tem um ponto que eu preciso
destacar para quem está preocupada com
sintomas da menopausa. O boro pode
ajudar a amenizar ondas de calor,
alterações de humor e distúrbios de
sono. Claro, ele não substitui uma
terapia hormonal quando ela é
necessária, mas por influenciar o
metabolismo de estrogênio endógeno e
reduzir a inflamação, ele pode dar
aquela força extra que muitas mulheres
estão precisando. Alguns estudos também
sugerem que o boro tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias, o que pode ajudar na
saúde das articulações e até melhorar a
função cerebral. Bom, e onde você
encontra o boro? Ele está presente em
alimentos de origem vegetal,
principalmente frutas como ameixas
secas, passas, damascos secos e
abacates. São excelentes fontes.
Vegetais de folhas verdes como couve,
espinafre também tem boro. Nozes,
amêndoas, avelã, feijões, lentilhas,
crão de bico, cacau, vinho e café também
contribuem pra ingestão desse mineral. A
dieta ocidental típica fornece entre 1 e
1,5 mg de boro por dia. Se você come uma
dieta rica em alimentos integrais e
vegetais, provavelmente está consumindo
de 1 a 2 mg naturalmente. Agora, quando
a gente fala de suplementação, vale
aquele cuidado sempre. Não é
sobreentopir o corpo de um monte de
coisa. A faixa considerada segura e
eficaz para adultos é de 3 a 6 mg por
dia. O limite superior tolerável
estabelecido por várias organizações
internacionais é de 20 mg por dia para
adultos. Então há uma margem de
segurança boa, mas como sempre é
importante não exagerar. Tos muito altas
acima de 500 mg por dia de ácido bórico,
que é uma forma de boro, já mostraram
causar desconforços gastrointestinais e
outros problemas. Mas isso está muito
longe das doses nutricionais que a gente
está falando aqui. Uma observação
importante, se você tem alguma condição
sensível a hormônios como câncer de
mama, dependente de o estrogênio,
endometriose, miomas uterinos ou câncer
de ovário, é preciso ter cautela com a
suplementação de boro, justamente porque
ele pode aumentar os níveis de
estrogênio. Então, nesses casos, uma
conversa cuidadosa e uma avaliação
individualizada são fundamentais. E tem
um dado fascinante que preciso
compartilhar. Pessoas com níveis baixos
de vitamina D tendem a ter níveis baixos
de boro também. Isso mostra que esses
dois nutrientes têm uma relação
sinégética no organismo. Eles trabalham
juntos. Se você está tomando vitamina D
e não está vendo os resultados
esperados, pode ser que o boro esteja em
falta. É essa visão de sistemas
interconectados que faz toda a diferença
numa abordagem integrativa. Então,
recapitulando, o boro é um mineral traço
que atua como um regulador metabólico
dos ossos e dos hormônios. Ele melhora a
retenção de cálcio e magnésio, aumenta
também a vida do estrogênio e da
vitamina D, potencializa a absorção de
nutrientes essenciais para os ossos e
pode ajudar a amenizar sintomas de
menopausa. Estudos de 2024 e 25
confirmaram que mulheres
póstmenopáusicas com maior ingestão de
boro tem melhor densidade de mineral
óssea e a melhor parte você pode
conseguir boas quantidades desse mineral
simplesmente comendo mais frutas,
vegetais, nozas e leguminosas. Se optar
pela suplementação, a faixa de 3 a 6 mg
por dia é segura e eficaz, sempre
respeitando o limite superior de 20 mg.
Esse é o tipo de informação que deveria
estar em todo o consultório, mas
raramente está. O boro é um daqueles
minerais esquecidos que podem fazer uma
diferença enorme na sua saúde óssea e
hormonal, especialmente se você é mulher
e está passando pela transição da
menopausa ou já está na pós-menopausa. É
uma peça pequena do quebra-cabeça, mas é
uma peça que pode estar faltando para
você completar a imagem de uma saúde
óssea e hormonal realmente sólida. Saia
do vídeo agora se você gosta de ficar um
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica, casos de
reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações off label que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Então temos lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF com
47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique, seja membro. E não é para
curioso, é para quem quer resultados.